sí
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález la xenofobia
está en aumento en américa latina' les
planteo esta pregunta a raíz de las
imágenes de los ataques contra migrantes
que tuvieron lugar en la ciudad de
iquique en el norte de chile que se
sumaron también al trato que se le está
dando a los migrantes en su travesía
hacia eeuu pasando por varios países de
la región una travesía que los lleva a
través del tapón del darién la selva que
separa a colombia de panamá y que muchos
de ellos hayan visto represados en el
puerto de necoclí en el norte de
colombia demos un vistazo cómo está la
situación de los migrantes y
principalmente hay en iquique
chile un sueño para los migrantes
atraídos por la fuerte economía chilena
miles de emigrantes decidieron cruzar la
frontera y aventurarse hacia el país
austral si bien en el millón 400 mil
inmigrantes provenientes de venezuela
que son los más numerosos también hay
peruanos haitianos y colombianos los
venezolanos que huyen de la crisis
siguen llegando en busca de nuevas
oportunidades
muchos de ellos entran por la frontera
con perú y bolivia la mayor cantidad de
haitianos llegó entre 2016 y 2017 cuando
podían entrar como turistas sin visa y
regularizar luego su situación si
encontraban trabajo al ver esa ola
migratoria en abril de 2018 el gobierno
de sebastián piñera abrió la posibilidad
para que cientos regularizarán su
situación jurídica
sabes cuando dejas
pequeño para un porvenir
pero cuando lo tiene en su país la
medida excedió las expectativas del
gobierno que retrocedió pidiendo pizzas
consulares según el ministerio del
interior de chile y la salida de
haitianos del país ha aumentado un 81
por ciento con respecto a 2020 la
cantidad de emigrantes sigue siendo alta
en la última semana los brotes de
xenofobia demuestran que un sector de la
población reciente su presencia al
acusarlos de quitarles el empleo y las
oportunidades en iquique la ciudad más
grande del norte la primera a la que
llegan los migrantes fue escenario de
violencia contra venezolanos las
imágenes causaron la condena mundial a
pesar de este panorama cientos de
personas entre ellos venezolanos aún
quieren migrar a chile con el sueño de
vivir en uno de los países más ricos de
suramérica
[Música]
es nuestro punto de partida pero ahora
vemos también un vistazo a algunas de
las cifras para ver cómo está la
migración contempla cifras muy altas en
nuestro territorio vamos a enfocarnos en
dos regiones específicamente en américa
del sur y en centroamérica y vamos a
comenzar en el extremo sur del
continente viendo cómo están allí las
cifras los 5 países que más emigrantes
emiten hacia otro territorio venezuela
ya contabiliza 5 millones 100 mil
emigrantes colombia 3 millones 24 mil en
tercer puesto está brasil con un millón
897.000 le sigue perú con un millón 500
19.000 cierra este top 5 ecuador con un
millón 127 mil en la región de
centroamérica el salvador es el país que
tiene la cifra más alta de emigrantes
desde este país ya han salido cerca de
un millón 599 mil personas le sigue
guatemala con un millón 368 mil
emigrantes honduras
985.000 le siguen nicaragua con 718 mil
y en quinta posición esta costa rica con
150 mil emigrantes cierra este panamá
con 139 mil 500 emigrantes
las sociedades y también la clase
política latinoamericana se muestran
completamente divididos en torno a los
derechos a las garantías que hay que
darles a los migrantes que siguen siendo
acusados de ser los causantes de la
inseguridad de la falta de empleo de la
falta de vacunas todo tipo de pretextos
que tanto hay de xenofobia que tanto es
un agotamiento por parte de los
ciudadanos ha sido muy mal manejada la
migración entre las naciones
latinoamericanas y donde están los
estados para atender estas emergencias
humanitarias ausentes tal parece que sí
presentes pues tal parece que no lo está
porque si están allí pues la situación
sería completamente diferente cómo tiene
que responder la región ante esta crisis
migratoria como la de haití como la de
centroamérica y la de venezuela el drama
migratorio en américa latina y también
la creciente migración y la creciente
xenofobia son nuestros temas de debate
hoy en france 24 para profundizar en
este tema saludamos a vanesa gonzález
ella es presidenta de la coordinación
nacional de inmigrantes en chile también
se encuentra con nosotros
el taller él es director del
observatorio de políticas migratorias de
la universidad católica cardenal raúl
silva henríquez y finalmente aquí en el
estudio de france 24 está con nosotros
lucía ramírez bolívar coordinadora de
investigaciones sobre migración en el
centro de estudios de derecho justicia y
sociedad también ustedes nuestros
televidentes pueden ser parte de esta
conversación a través de sus preguntas y
todos sus comentarios en nuestras redes
sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram en twitter también síganos
como france24
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios comienzo por lucia aquí
en el estudio de france 24 preguntándole
haciéndole la pregunta con la que
empezamos a este programa está la
xenofobia en aumento en américa latina
es el mal que está afectando la
migración si definitivamente la
xenofobia está creciendo en la región y
yo creo que los el ejemplo de chile es
sólo uno de muchos de hecho ya habíamos
visto una situación similar en brasil en
roraima en 2018 lo que sentimos y vemos
de justicia recientemente también
publicamos un informe sobre el tema
comparando de hecho los tres principales
países receptores de población migrante
venezolana perú colombia y chile es que
la pandemia ha incrementado esa
xenofobia precisamente por la crisis
económica que están viviendo nuestros
países muchas comunidades que ya de por
sí eran vulnerables también están
recibiendo población migrante en
situación de vulnerabilidad y esa
digamos situación de falta de acceso a
recursos crisis económica generalizada
se ha aumentado en los sentimientos
nacionalistas son analizando las cifras
uno ve como aumentaron antes y después
de la pandemia y de hecho el 44 por
ciento de las personas venezolanas
manifiestan sentirse discriminadas
entonces evidentemente estamos
enfrentando una crisis con respecto a la
xenofobia crisis contra la xenofobia de
la xenofobia le pregunto ahora a vanessa
en la ciudad de santiago en chile sobre
este panorama sus impresiones están
aumento la xenofobia en nuestra región
como lo vio usted
pero en efecto hoy día la memoria de
inmigrantes nos encontramos dos trenes
realmente asbestos que no solamente este
año sino los de hace unos años ya ya
hemos estado manifestando lo que
justamente ver a christina de la
deshumanización de quitarse las comunes
migrantes no de la criminalización de
proyecta deshumanización en donde
justamente está la mesa en el marco de
la sociedad incluso a través del
discurso de medios de comunicación y de
autoridades en contra de las personas
migrantes
responsabilizando la migración de los
problemas experimenta el país o incluso
que experimenta la región esto por
supuesto es completamente dañino puesto
que lo que hace justamente promover no
es una mirada de la migración no desde
justamente comprender los verdaderos
motivos es que la expuesta sino
justamente criminalista de implementar
digamos miradas
que llevan a los estados a proponer
políticas más bien restrictivas
que ya vamos a analizar ese punto
también vanessa luís eduardo para
completar esta primera pregunta para
conocer las opiniones generales y el
panorama xenofobia en aumento hartazgo
ciudadano
se están sumando diferentes aspectos en
una crisis en una coyuntura en la que
está la región como lo ve usted
y es bueno la pregunta porque uno lo
puede llevar hacia porque surge la
xenofobia o porque emergió porque crece
y yo creo que se juntan aquí varios
factores en caso particular de chile se
da primero como señalaba a padres ante
un relato un relato sobre la migración
como producto en el que se viene
insistiendo hace ya bastante tiempo hace
ya algunos años que se viene señalando
esta relación entre migración y
problemas en el empleo diversión y el
problema en salud migración y problemas
de seguridad en nuestras calles vale
decir se le imputa a las personas
migrantes los problemas que tienen es
nuestro modelo de desarrollo por otra
parte tenemos en chile hoy día vamos me
hay una campaña presidencial lo cual
permite de alguna manera exacerbada y
masterizar a las personas migrantes en
función de tener réditos políticos y
finalmente creo que hay un factor muy
importante en la ausencia total de
políticas de inclusión de colectivo
migrante en este territorio y en otros
países de expresión también vale decir
la migración y el proceso de integración
que es la sucede no se produce
espontáneamente
en natural creo yo que las personas
viven en contextos precarios como los de
nuestros países o al borde de la recaída
sientan ese hombre y no qué hay que
hacer con las políticas migratorias es
evitar ya que es incertidumbre se
convierte en odio en xenofobia el
racismo y en violencia en contra de la
persona mira usted toca varios de los
temas que tengo aquí en la mesa para
para analizar a lo largo del programa
hago la ronda a la inversa sigo con
louis entonces y paso a preguntarle
usted menciona varios aspectos pero
quiero preguntarle por el aspecto de las
leyes la parte legislativa se está
manejando mal a nivel de los estados
estos procesos migratorios que no son
nuevos en nuestra región porque ya en el
pasado vimos argentino saliendo de la
dictadura yendo hacia venezuela
colombianos yendo hacia venezuela
centroamericanos que constantemente han
estado yendo hacia eeuu incluso
brasileños o uruguayos también
moviéndose un poco hacia el norte no es
una novedad de nuestra región entonces
que lo que está fallando ahora en la
parte legislativa
porque sé que las leyes que jalisco las
leyes que ganó un piso las
constituciones juegan un piso y los
compromisos internacionales fijan un
piso pero las políticas avanzan sobre
aquello la ley sola no era suficiente y
si bien hay leyes en américa que tienen
leyes muy dispares y constituciones que
tratan la vibración de manera muy dispar
tenemos constituciones como la
ecuatoriana muy muy muy abierta alguna
política una ley también muy acogedora
respecto a la inmigración pero el día
estamos viendo 2014 una política
una política que no es acogedora no
reconoce los derechos entonces tenemos
que pensar no sólo en leyes que sean más
realistas más concordantes con la
realidad regional y políticas que
también
se orienten en esa dirección si tenemos
políticas que pretenden ponerle puertas
al campo tapar el sol con un conteo y
desconocer la realidad que tenemos
dentro dentro del continente lo único
que vamos a generar es incrementar la
precariedad e incrementar la sensación
de temor
y escribieron amigas y un poco el
sentimiento de descontrol que esa es la
pregunta que le quiero hacer a vanessa
precisamente por esta falta de políticas
acertadas y de leyes que den un buen
soporte se está dando una migración
completamente desorganizada porque
además están llegando los migrantes a
unos puntos fronterizos en donde no hay
ni siquiera presencia del estado tomó el
caso de colombia esa frontera selvática
con panamá en donde ni siquiera para los
habitantes de necoclí hay presencia del
estado por completo y llegan a atender
ahora a esta cantidad de migrantes que
se están regresando allí
pero en efecto como mencionaron que si
bien la migración es un proceso
histórico humano y también es un derecho
para los de posicionamos nosotros la
organización es que mirar es un derecho
humano fundamental y más en estos
tiempos evidentemente el haber
experimentado procesos que evidencia que
migraciones que justamente
son muy por motivos que son también más
cortados no y justamente la región en su
conjunto no los países tienen que
comprometerse a adoptar medidas de que
estén justamente en salvaguardar la los
derechos de estas personas nos porque
estamos entendiendo que esto propuesto
con especial protección y en este
sentido lo que hemos visto son graves
retrocesos o sea celebrar tus textos de
material únicamente de implementar
políticas de inclusión a migrantes como
conectaba eduardo pero asumen objeto
como aumentado en conflicto con la
criminalización medidas para reprimir o
como por ejemplo en el caso de las
destrucciones colectivas que son el ex
producidas por el derecho internacional
y que el chile comenzó a ejecutar por
ejemplo este año
eso por supuesto no tiene muy han armado
porque estas medidas son contrarias a
regular la migración
esto los regulares no reprimir la
vibración y nuevamente sobre esto
ineficiente cuando estamos hablando de
textos tienes que son de carácter
humanitario no lejos de regular la
migración evidentemente no ha sido
segura regular y ordenada para las
personas migrantes de los propios países
chile está mal es un llamado a la región
justamente preguntar sanitario regional
pero nos ha comentado también dejen de
reprimir no es ser un poco el llamado
que justamente se hace porque otra la
renuncia este proyecto decir acá este
además de reprimir pero un poco la
migración y de y de aumentar la
presencia policial en fronteras de
militarizar las fronteras no junto con
cierre de fronteras con la pandemia
también se ha obstruido el ingreso
regular es el caso de chile en donde
justamente vemos que hay una correlación
entre impedir el ingreso regular a las
personas y la migración
claro aquí en el estudio de france 24
lucía impresiones sobre estos puntos que
tocan los otros dos invitados y también
le plantea otra pregunta sobre una
posible respuesta a nivel regional hasta
américa latina' le cuesta mucho
integrarse para todo tipo de cosas pero
tal vez la migración puede hacer una
respuesta para empezar a dar pasos en
conjunto como lo ve usted sí pues lo
primero es reiterar lo que dijeron los
colegas y es que si ha habido un
retroceso en los últimos cinco años en
las políticas de hecho nosotros antes en
la región teníamos unas políticas que
permitían el libre tránsito solamente
con la presentación de ciertos
documentos y eso se ha venido
restringiendo a lo largo de estos cinco
años y además ha venido digamos
acompañado de respuestas que nos
preocupan mucho como la militarización
entonces durante la pandemia hemos visto
que tres países perú chile y colombia
han militarizado sus fronteras en
distintos momentos y eso aún pone más en
riesgo a las personas migrantes y
refugiadas riesgos de violaciones de
derechos humanos por parte de los mismos
estados y además transmite una imagen de
que la migración genera inseguridad y
desde estado se está mandando el mensaje
con militares que las personas migrantes
no pueden llegar pues quiere eso refleja
una imagen hacia adentro de que las
personas migrantes pueden generar
riesgos y eso alimenta la respuesta a su
vez de la ciudadanía y es era un punto
que yo quisiera resaltar y es si no
tenemos políticas que realmente acojan
integren pues no podemos esperar tampoco
otra respuesta de la ciudadanía y los
funcionarios públicos deben ser los
primeros en dar el ejemplo no va a hacer
discursos que reproduzcan estos
estereotipos no hacer manifestaciones
que los vinculen con los temas de
seguridad o con el acceso a recursos
limitados etcétera sur y frente a tu
pregunta definitivamente había unos
esfuerzos en el pasado por ejemplo el
proceso de quito el proceso de lima pero
no hemos visto resultados concretos de
esas políticas integradoras de hecho
muchos de los estados han manifestado
incluso colombia pues la invitación a
otros países también a buscar medidas
similares como el estatuto de protección
temporal porque si no nos ponemos de
acuerdo para cómo vamos a responder a la
migración en la región pues eso va a
hacer que ciertos países sean mucho más
restrictivos y otros tengan que asumir
mayores con unos recursos limitados
definitivamente es muy necesario que
haya coordinación entre los estados
realmente efectivas porque ha habido
muchas reuniones ha habido compromisos
pero no necesariamente se implementan
adecuadamente usted habla de los
recursos pero siempre américa latina
tiene las bajo la manga para decir no
hay plata para poder hacer este tipo de
cosas no hay plata para para poder
sortear esta crisis y vemos también por
ejemplo un país como eeuu que ha dicho
nosotros nos vamos a poder controlar
esta crisis migratoria en la frontera
tenemos que aliarnos con mexico ayudemos
entre los dos porque eeuu no lo va a
poder hacer solo si eso lo hace eeuu que
es la primera economía del mundo que
podemos esperar entonces de los países
latinoamericanos países de tránsito como
por ejemplo nicaragua honduras o
guatemala que allí también han empezado
a represarse algunos de los migrantes
que ya no pueden llegar a méxico yo creo
que ahí es una respuesta también un poco
hipócrita por parte de los estados del
norte global y ese no es solamente el
caso de eeuu sino de otros países en
europa por ejemplo si uno mira las
cifras los países del sur por ejemplo
los estados de latinoamérica y en otras
regiones del sur global reciben el 70
por ciento de las personas desplazadas
forzadamente y solo tenemos cerca del 5
10% del producto interno bruto global
mientras que los países del norte tienen
el 66 por ciento es el producto interno
bruto y reciben solamente el 10 por
ciento de las personas refugiadas
entonces creo que además amerita una
reflexión más global y me parece también
paradójica la respuesta de eeuu cuando
frente a la crisis de afganistán ha
dicho que va a financiar a muchas de las
personas migrantes que van a reubicar en
otros países mientras se tramitan sus
casos y me pregunto si también es
necesario que la cooperación
internacional pues responda de manera
más decidida a la situación de países
como colombia chile perú que requieren
pues una red un apoyo económico para
poder responder a la migración vanessa
en la ciudad de santiago
hace unos meses veíamos a la
vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris en
su visita por centroamérica diciéndole
precisamente a los centroamericanos no
vengan a eeuu no es el momento para
venir en este momento a nuestro país no
intenten llegar acá no intenten venir a
nuestro país
decía que había que comenzar a atacar la
migración o hacerle frente a la crisis a
través de mecanismos en los países
haciéndole frente a las crisis de los
países por eso destinaron unos fondos
para méxico y para el triángulo del
norte precisamente para mejorar la
situación económica y para que la gente
no tenga que irse a estos países hacia
eeuu cómo hacer frente a la situación
que está viviendo haití y venezuela que
es por ejemplo su país que se puede
hacer de raíz en estos dos casos que son
los más críticos
yo creo que es una pregunta además de
bastante compleja porque justamente
estamos suponiendo que estamos viendo
que hay grupos que se han visto forzado
a migrar por las pruebas a situaciones
complejas y las crisis mostrar en sus
países evidentemente las comunidades
migrantes no queremos que los países
en ese empezado es así que por demás
obligando a otras personas a migrar y es
por eso que sin duda alguna no solamente
responsabilidad tanto los actores
políticas dentro de los países no son
cosas que te sucede con los grupos que
se han visto empujado a migrar pero sino
también es una responsabilidad global de
asumir que la migración no se va dt
porque aunque se puede solucionar
digamos que la situación que de christie
que experimentó un país nosotros podemos
suponer que las migraciones van a
continuar a la luz de los cambios que
experimentan las distintas regiones pero
tal vez incluso de factores como el
cambio climático
y eso une con el mundo que vivimos hoy
día y es por eso que la migración
debería considerarse como un derecho
humano fundamental más allá de
simplemente analistas
digamos las razones por las que la
movilidad humana es un gran desafío para
la humanidad muy grandes activos para
los estados y lleva un asunto sumamente
reiterado que más va a seguir existiendo
y pues no podemos seguir oponiéndonos a
realidad
luís eduardo también hay en santiago sus
impresiones sobre lo que han dicho
nuestras dos invitadas y le preguntó por
el caso chileno que le está faltando a
chile para poder hacer frente a esta
situación porque está siendo criticado
señalado a nivel internacional usted ya
lo decía las políticas no están
funcionando pero se está mostrando como
un país muy rígido para hacer frente a
este tema
y falta realismo falta integración
regional
tiene forma parte de la cuarta
residencia del cónsul ya falta
operacional izando operativizar lo
hacerlo digamos para ponerlo en mapas
efectivamente yo creo que lo que está
mostrando chile es la crisis de un
modelo de otra política migratoria
centrado en la frontera
basado en un relato de la migración como
un lastre para una sociedad que
desconoce completamente las políticas de
inclusión y que pretende resolver
[Música]
y aquí sin integración sin colaboración
y sin diálogo con el resto del estado
pero que no se va a resolver y piensa en
diálogo de dos tipos en integración
desde dos tipos primero hay que ver cómo
como región cumplimos nuestros
compromisos internacionales que no se
están cumpliendo en materia refugio
no sé tenemos que resolver primero por
menos abertura la composición
ternacional es que anteriores y luego
pensar una política de integración
regional que incluya la migración sé que
nosotros a diferencia de europa de eeuu
y de otro sistema migratorio
tenemos una particularidad y tenemos la
particularidad de que somos las regiones
expulsoras la región receptora de las
personas migrantes y somos países con
niveles de desarrollo similar y somos
países donde recíprocamente viven
personas de los países emisores
receptores y transitan también las
personas entonces somos la región ya que
está en mejor posición para resolver
para abordar el tema de la vibración
desde el punto de vista de integración
entonces si no lo hacemos es que nos
falta nacionalidad y nos falta realismo
creo que tenemos que avanzar
necesariamente y de manera urgente en
esa línea y nos falta un poco humanizar
este drama louis no le parece a usted
pero sin revictimizar a estas personas
que han pasado por situaciones muy
complejas y nos está faltando un poco
humanizar la situación entender la
hermandad latinoamericana compartimos el
mismo idioma el mismo
a nivel cultural prácticamente tenemos
cosas muy parecidas nos unen muchísimas
raíces y nos cuesta integrarnos entre
nosotros y entender que nos podemos
movilizar de un país a otro
a los estados les para actualizarse
nosotros hemos visto el iquique como las
organizaciones sociales el tejido de
la sociedad se ha movilizado para apoyar
a las personas
y algunos grupos vociferantes en 30
estados gyan ghana y medio pero aquí la
sociedad nuestros pueblos tienen
solidarias y aparte lo que vivimos
1b en muchos territorios muchas zonas
muchas huelgas que se generen se
producen en lazos solidarios lo que
faltan son estados organizaciones
instituciones que eligen en estos
procesos lo que tenemos de 10 sociedades
que en muchos casos avanzan en proceso
de integración que digamos acogen a las
personas migran pero apoyan y estados
que van por otro lado estados que van en
compra muchas veces de estas
digamos dinámicas sociales que se dan en
muchos casos generando entonces sirven
falta sal pero sobre todo falta matizar
el estado amanecer le pregunto ahora por
un tema que me llama la atención y es
como esto se le da un manejo político se
ha utilizado ya lo decía luis para fines
políticos en la campaña que ya le va a
preguntar por el caso chileno más
adelante se instruye se ha
instrumentalizado
político a favor de ciertos gobiernos a
favor de nicolás maduros de si está o no
a favor de su de su forma de gobierno a
favor de los castro en cuba o de otros
países de la región como colombia en fin
ha sido utilizado a todo nivel
políticamente
ya nosotros nos parece
vergonzoso y lamentable como distintas
historias políticas y de distintos
sectores políticos
vamos adopta mente la temática
migratorio por mencionarlo esta manera
con distintos del curso pero justamente
para poder en por externos favorecer
digamos la influencia o favorecer un
poco la punta aunque que puede tener la
ciudadanía con estos grupos pero nos
parece vergonzoso porque si bien se han
prometido muchas cosas no hablamos por
ejemplo desde el gobierno actual en el
que ha prometido apoyar por ejemplo
países específicos en el ámbito como
nuevamente estos discursos son
simplemente discurso vacío cuando se
trata justamente de implementar medidas
a favor de migrantes
están experimentando países
bueno de las comunidades migrantes en
general en favor de los derechos humanos
entonces nosotros como organizaciones
comunidades que utilizan
utilización y sin utilizar isco con
respecto a la migración porque en la
práctica de la comunidad ya grande no ha
tenido ningún tipo de
beneficio respecto nosotros hemos
llamado las personas no solamente es
apertura sino en general a que fueran
nuevamente
responde no responder comedias efectiva
y no solamente digamos asustar a la
migración a ser convenir
aquí nos preocupa de esto que justamente
cuando hablamos de que distintos estar
abusando llevaría sin recoger uno de los
sectores más peligrosos es que utiliza
justamente la migración para extra
observar los nacionalismos y proponer
por ejemplo en colocar muros dos hojas
es
peligroso y queremos
son casos que hemos visto ya varias
veces a lo largo de la historia lucia le
preguntó por el caso colombia en un país
que ha estado bajo presión en el tema
migratorio es la frontera más grande
inmediata para los venezolanos para
emprender su camino ya sea hacia el sur
del continente o hacia eeuu colombia
está bajo presión en este momento están
por abrir la frontera para casos muy
específicos pero esto cree usted que
puede generar una nueva ola migratoria
desde venezuela porque también vemos que
hace unos días publicaron un informe en
donde dicen que cerca del 70% de la
población vive en la pobreza la
situación allí está complicada a raíz de
la pandemia yo creo que ya las personas
estaban migrando con la frontera cerrada
no no veo que vaya a haber una llegada
masiva porque además el abrir la
frontera va a tener unos controles hay
un pico y cédula van a pedir unos
documentos entonces solo las personas
que tengan por ejemplo pasaporte van a
poder o un documento colombiano van a
poder ingresar al país las personas que
tienen que emigrar y regularmente no
porque quieren sino porque enfrentan
barreras documentación muy graves es muy
difícil conseguir un pasaporte en
venezuela pues van a tener que seguir
viniendo con las por las trochas y eso
obviamente las expone a muchos riesgos
en el camino extorsión trata de personas
violaciones de derechos humanos entonces
no veo que vaya a llegar un flujo masivo
por la frontera si veo que va a
facilitar intercambios comerciales y eso
va a ser muy importante para los
municipios de ambos lados de la frontera
muchas personas vienen a cúcuta para
comprar bienes y servicios y luego de
esa plata circula en el mismo país
porque por lo general son remesas que
vienen de otras personas migrantes que
están aquí en colombia o de otros países
de la región entonces una economía que
necesita moverse y que en ese sentido va
a ser una medida muy positiva también
todo el tránsito de niños que vienen a
estudiar a colombia entonces estábamos
realmente en mora de abrir la frontera
pero a pesar de los esfuerzos que ha
hecho colombia con el estatuto temporal
y demás si nos preocupa mucho avanzando
este tema en colombia pues va
relativamente bien se han inscrito
varias personas a través del registro
único en la página web
pues ya se está avanzando en la
recolección de datos biométricos pero si
tenemos varias preocupaciones por
ejemplo con las personas que no tienen
acceso a internet que no tienen
competencias pues para la tecnología
porque eso obviamente afecta a su
posibilidad de acceder a una medida tan
importante y dos pues que sólo va a
cubrir a las personas que hayan entrado
antes del 31 de enero y regularmente de
aquí en adelante serán solo las que
entren por punto autorizado de manera
regular así que los que sigan entrando
de manera irregular pues no van a poder
acogerse a este beneficio y no tenemos
en nuestra baraja de opciones alguna
ruta que se les pueda ofrecer en ese
caso en tus van a seguir enfrentando
barreras de acceso a derechos que nos
preocupan mucho complicada la situación
cruzo ahora a luis eduardo tengo
pendiente ya para la parte final del
programa preguntarle por el tema
electoral ya lo mencionaba si le está
empezando prácticamente ya la campaña de
cara a la presidencia va a ser un tema
álgido va a ser un tema predominante en
la agenda como lo vio usted de cara a
esas presidenciales allí en su país
sin duda el que lo va a hacer o se ha
hecho el tema migratorio surge en chile
en la agenda como un tema
a capitalizar políticas
surge en 2016 a propósito de una campaña
de utilizar lo anterior antes de vida
por el éxito de tram por su discurso en
eeuu nuestro discurso ante mirada y
aparece el tele la gente luego el
gobierno de pidiera lo que hace es
permanentemente instrumentalizar el tema
para capturar la adhesión ciudadana
utilizar expulsiones transmitidas por
televisión para calmar conflictos que
estaban conflictos sociales que estaban
surgiendo por los dramas de otros
sistemas de la instrumentalización
política
para capitalizar adhesión ciudadana no
es algo propio de esta campaña y en esta
campaña ha alcanzado ya límites
significativos como límites que hemos
visto antes a propósito de los de quique
911 efectivamente hay un malestar creo
yo por la ausencia de políticas de
integración y de acogida humanitaria
respecto de la coyuntura que se está
viviendo y la instalación de grupos
digamos que están explícitamente
apoyando a ciertas candidaturas de
extrema derecha principalmente
que están utilizando esto como un
dispositivo de campaña entonces lo más
probable es que hacia adelante siga y
siga presente en la agenda de la campaña
entendido luis le pregunto a vanessa
ahora por las organizaciones a nivel
internacional han dado la respuesta
adecuada para manejar esta crisis en la
región han omitido hacer presencia
garantizar derechos humanos garantizar
en todo tipo de deberes que deben de
estar haciendo allí estas organizaciones
internacionales cuál es su opinión
con afortunadamente hemos visto por
ejemplo lo largo del año
laterales derechos humanos y tanto de
búsqueda no se han pronunciado
justamente desde la preocupación de los
estados
nuevamente sigan entablar las medidas
represivas yo también afortunadamente
vivimos
en iquique no y nosotros justamente de
la sociedad escribir y desde la gestión
integrada pro migrante que toma
normalmente seguimos siendo el estado en
este caso particularmente en chile que
las recomendaciones que le están
haciendo organismos internacionales no
interamericana de derechos humanos
y una de ellas creo que todas las
organizaciones
en el mes de abril
e incluso
estos criterios
pues se me acaba el tiempo para este
debate a vanessa luís eduardo y ha
lucido aquí en el estudio de france 24
les agradezco haber compartido con
nosotros sus impresiones y opiniones
sobre este tema ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus preguntas y sus comentarios
a través de las redes sociales de france
24 les recuerdo también que el debate
está ahora de lunes a viernes de lunes a
jueves perdón a las 7 y 20 hora de
bogotá siga con nuestra programación
[Música]